[Musique]
notre prochaine conférence y est un
jeune entrepreneur comme vous pouvez
voir vincent rottiers vincent qui est un
passionné de plein chose comme
certainement plusieurs d'entrepreneurs
en ce moment il est passionné par le
génie mécanique par la musique le cinéma
les multis les multimédias les logiciels
est ce que j'en oublie raison non c'est
un bon groupe on s'appelle tous alors
vincent est venu nous raconter un
événement assez particulier qu'il a vécu
il y à peine quelques mois notre
aventure a commencé le 3 février dernier
quand on a mis en ligne une vidéo sans
aucune attente
cette vidéo l'a peut-être que parmi vous
certaines personnes l'ont vu
le samedi matin quand je me suis
réveillé j'avais 800 à 1000 personnes
qui le dit et des dizaines de médias qui
nous ont écrit pour nous c'est quoi ça
pour vous donner une idée à quel point
on n'avait pas d'attendre par rapport à
cette vie boulot mon amie catherine qui
est enseignante à l'école l'externat
saint jean vers nantes où on a fait
cette vidéo le soir à midi on appelle ça
comme un j'aime interactif interactive
jim et le 4 février connu cette surprise
le on savait pas ce qui nous attend des
papiers aventure qui allait commencer et
comme jean marie disait je parcours un
peu atypique qui m'a amené à toucher à
toutes sortes de choses dans ma carrière
d'entrepreneur d'homme d'affaires de
créateurs il maintient espèce
d'équilibré entre ma vie personnelle
mais les 1000 jeunes enfants vous voyons
ce qu'en mangeant les lyonnais qui ont 3
et 5 1 les lyonnais rentrent à l'école
l'année prochaine je veux demander
comment connecter où trouver l'équilibré
entre mon expertise professionnelle puis
ma vie de nouveaux panneaux
j'aimais fille allait rentrer à l'école
je me disais qu'est ce que moi je
regarde atteint va rater ou de cris qui
pourrait peut-être devenir un outil qui
prennent leur permet d'avoir une
traversée dans ce milieu de l'éducation
là qui pourrait peut-être inspirante ou
aux dépens et le 17 janvier quelques
mois quelques quelques jours mais avant
le 3 février ailleurs professeur génial
qui a mis en ligne une vidéo sur
internet qui devenu viral le 40
milliards 40 millions de visionnements
de 40 millions de visionnements
en l'espace d'une semaine ou deux en
fait j'ai pris une application qui
s'appelle jetten qui est une indication
pour les chiens pour les ipad ayant fait
quand on passe cette application pour
l'ipad ya des petites bulles qui se
promènent sur l'ipad qui le show avec
ses pattes pas automatiquement avant le
réflexe de les écraser
c'est assez intéressant pour les chats
mais pour les enfants puisque fait en
fait ce qui a plu le ipad le brancher
sur un projecteur qui a dit aux enfants
lancez-vous ballon sur les 1,5 je vous
allez voir ce qui va se passer de lui
derrière avec son doigt y écraser les
insectes quand les ballons a créé 2
à peu près au bon moment je me suis fait
à guînes sur facebook est à peu près 50
fois dans cette vidéo la 25e capable de
faire ça ça fait des années qu'on fait
de la recherche et développement pour
des choses vraiment vraiment compliqué
que ça mais on avait quand même toute
l'expertisé qu'il fallait pour le faire
donc le 1er février
ce que vous voyez c'est la cuisine de
mon associé ciment avec un prototype de
on lance une balle de ping pong sur un
écran et explose 1er février 2 février
dans mon bureau
le premier jeu vidéo avec l'idée du
ballon qui va écraser les espèces
d'insectes qu'on était plus haut niveau
technique on se dit qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire avec ça mais qui a de
l'envergure on vient du monde spectacle
on a mis en scène des toutes sortes de
choses on a raconté des histoires vous
faudrait le faire plus grande envergure
donc le vendredi après midi dans l'après
midi le vendredi après-midi le 3 février
on voit dans l'externat st lambert mende
lundi pour ce soir gigantesque pour que
les jeunes qui bougent pour que les
jeunes s'amusent en bougeant qu'on a
mais l'éclairage ont fait une projection
de cette grande ampleur dans un gymnase
ou fermer les lumières parce que sinon
on voit pas bien la projection mais si
on ferme les lumières dans un gymnase si
on dit aux enfants les discours lancer
des ballons faire suspens c'est un
superbe ça prend de l'éclair est le
temps qui a installé l'éclairage on va
le contrôler cet éclairage le pour que
quand les gens me perdre une vie dans le
jeu les jeunes ans de viande rouge au
complet ça lui ouvre un espèce de boîte
de pandore on ne savait pas trop encore
embarqué on faisait ça je vais vraiment
par plaisait tout a déboulé tout a
déboulé à partir de le fête le 4 février
quand on s'est réveillé
on a réalisé qu'il y avait un super bel
intérêt qui potentiellement rayasse gens
ne réalisent une chose tous les jeunes
aiment jouer mais c'est pas tous les
jeunes qui aiment faire du sport mais
s'ils jouaient à bout j'ai joué en
faisant du sport ou qu'on a une
dimension qui normalement est un peu
contradictoire les des jeux vidéo et de
l'éducation physique dans les écoles
c'est des sujets qui sont opposés
un destin emprunt les deux qui on essaie
de faire on prend le maire comprend les
mécaniques de jeu vidéo l'immersion le
storytelling que dans un jeu vidéo mais
on l'amène dans le monde physique
quand on va prendre le gym danse
l'environnement physique mais on va donc
créer un environnement dans lequel les
jeunes vont à l'impression d'être dans
un jeu lui et ça c'est les mots d'un
jeune qui ne s'en sont pas à sa mère le
4 février j'ai reçu un message on
mangeait de l'expérimenté votre votre
activité dans l'après midi
c'est super il m'a dit j'étais dans un
jeu vidéo est assez intéressant l'idée
de aimez bouger ou de faire aimer bouger
grâce aux jeux vidéo
maintenant ça s'appelle lui est lui très
bon on en a vendu dans tout plein de vie
on est rendu à peu près 25 millions de
visionnements de nos vidéos qui ont été
mis en
on a toutes sortes de guider ou de
vision de où on va pouvoir ramener tous
et éventuellement ce que vous voyez sur
l'écran derrière moi c'est c'est notre
premier notre première configuration du
vous faites ces deux écrans face à face
à collier d'intérêt en interaction
seulement avec un écran et 10 dans celui
là c'est d'avoir deux écrans face à face
raconte utilisent les planches et aussi
entre les deux écrans pour faire bouger
les gens dans ce jeu dans ce jeu là les
jeunes doivent carrière au ballon dans
les mains ne peuvent pas bouger comme
ultimate frisbee ou un bal avec doit
faire une passe à un coéquipier qui en
progressant vers le but proposer de
faire des points
le carreau lensois un but qui ont fait
un point dans un bus ou en métal avec la
corde
en effet jusqu'à 4 m et qu'enfin un plus
dans un jeu vidéo qui peut avoir un jeu
spécial qui commençait à voir avec ça
amène beaucoup de possibilités
d'ouverture
ensuite l'idée d'avoir d'abord installé
ça dans un dans un gymnase pour faire du
sport à lui évolué même si bas qu'on a
récemment fait un jeu de français où on
apprend et clermont lance le ballon sur
l'île est dans la bonne séquence pour
épeler un moment que j'allais dire une
matière scolaire entrer tranquillement
orange innove
puis l'idée de faire des mathématiques
du calcul mental qui c'est un projet
qu'on a fait par instinct par deux papas
qui se disaient qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec nos expertises pour nos
jeunes et tout
et en creusant en comptera des
chercheurs des professionnels on a
réalisé que apprendre en bougeant ça
ouvre beaucoup de possibilités l'horizon
au niveau de la capacité d'apprendre et
apprendre par le jeu aussi énormément de
l'application éventuelle qui sortait est
ce que tes filles ont eu l'occasion
d'essayer
le jus des papas jusqu'à maintenant on
essaye de 12 et ça parce que sinon on
peut y jouer quand même arrivé à l'école
mais ayant chacun leurs jeux préférés
qui l'anniversaire de leoni qui était
quelques semaines s'est passé dans un
espace comme celui-là ça les fait
plusieurs plusieurs défis vont se faire
facilement les amis avec ce petit jeu-là
fortis
c'est bon pas fait ça donc il ya un
avancement par rapport à ce que tu viens
de nous raconter ça s'est passé dans les
derniers mois ça va à une vitesse très
très grande mais aussi pour connaître
les entrepreneurs surtout
multidimensionnelle comme tulle et dans
ta tête j'imagine qu'il ya d'autres
choses qui nous attend assez
prochainement
absolument donc une maintenant notre
mission c'est de concevoir d'inventer le
gymnase du 21e siècle
les jumeaux sont pas changé depuis les
100 dernières années s'il commence à
être temps changent
je pense qu'on a un fils ont assez
intéressant pour le faire de la manière
que nous on voit le gym danse c'est un
immense espace dans un école qui peut
servir à plein de choses en jeu servait
aux sports ou page et servir à apprendre
il pourrait servir aux autres plastiques
à la musique qu'on a toutes sortes de
jeux ou d'applications qui s'en viennent
qui vont faire que tout ce qu'on va
faire à l'école tout les types
d'expertisé ou de d'activités qu'on a le
goût développé comme jeunes dans une
école de faire développer à des jeunes
on voit aussi de créer un outil qui va
permettre de le faire
le faire bien qu'ils donnent de d'aider
les jeunes à développer leur passion de
postes limitées seulement à certains
trucs décès d'ouvrir ce système pourra
l'allier qui comprend les moyens de
concevoir des jeux éventuellement qui
essayant d'être le plus le plus ouvert
possible
je pense que beaucoup de plaisir qui
nous attend a dit syed et enseignants
dans la salle aujourd'hui
probablement qu'ils sont en train des
jeunes d'imaginer comment ils vont
changer justement la façon
l'apprentissage avec les jeunes vincent
c'est un monde qui s'ouvre vers
l'éducation aussi j'imagine que vous
allez aller vers les gens peut parler
d'eux par vous avez échangé avec des
gens qui font de la recherche sur la
pédagogie alors une colle du futur
peut-être ça donne envie de retourner à
l'école merci beaucoup vers un merci
[Applaudissements]